[clicking noises]
Shotaro Makisumi:
I got involved in cubing a really long time
ago. When I was nine, about, someone taught me how
Shotaro Makisumi:
to solve a Rubik's cube, and at that time
I wasn't really using any advanced method.
Shotaro Makisumi:
I probably solved it in about 2 minutes. It
was after several months that I was getting
Shotaro Makisumi:
high-20 seconds, and then I still had a long
road ahead to get down to 15 seconds.
Shotaro Makisumi:
Yeah, it took a lot of practice.
I started the Rubik's Cube club at Princeton
in 2009, and I have a couple friends now who
Shotaro Makisumi:
are speed cubers also on campus. We try to meet
every week and, usually, it is just cubing and
Shotaro Makisumi:
having fun.
Alan Chang:
When I came to Princeton, I was not really
surprised to find that there was a Rubik's
Alan Chang:
Cube club here, because at that time there
were already a lot of Rubik's Cube clubs in
Alan Chang:
the colleges near where I lived. And, the
fact that Macky goes to Princeton, I knew that
Alan Chang:
he must have started a club here.
Shotaro Makisumi:
I am expecting about 100 competitors for this
event. Among the pre-registered competitors,
Shotaro Makisumi:
there is the current U.S. champion and a couple
of former and current world record holders.
Shotaro Makisumi:
There are also seven other countries, or nationalities,
represented, aside from the U.S. This competition is going
Shotaro Makisumi:
to be one of the big ones this fall on the
East Coast.
[music]
Shotaro Makisumi:
I have always wanted to organize a big competition.
So, I think being a student organization here
Shotaro Makisumi:
has really, really helped me to get this idea that
I had to come true.
[clicking noises]
Shirley M. Tilghman:
[laughing, clapping] Congratulations!